vectors can be represented through their
components if we have a vector a we can
decompose it into its components in the
X and y directions by finding the
vectors one along X and one along Y then
add up to the vector a this is the same
thing as finding the projections of the
vector a along the x and y axes here is
the projection of the vector onto the x
axis its X component and here is the
projection onto the y axis the Y
component this particular vector can be
written as ay is equal to minus 2 I hat
plus minus 2 J hat a generic vector in
two dimensions can be written as a is
equal to ax the X component of a times I
hat the unit vector along X plus a Y the
Y component times J hat the unit vector
along Y if the vector is in three
dimensions we will also have an AZ times
K hat what if we have the vector minus
3i hat plus 2 J hat first we find the
vector minus three times the unit vector
AI hat and add this to the the vector 2
times J hat we can draw this vector
anywhere it doesn't have to start at the
origin